[Music]
hey guys my name is Raya and here's a
story about how I met 25 thousand people
so I'm taking guys back about a year ago
on July 29th 2017 I turned 27
and that was the day it hit me I'm 27
I'm working oh you see after college I
realized that there are three main
things I wanted to do with my life one I
wanted to meet more people - I wanted to
share more stories and three I wanted to
make more films and here I was five
years later and I had done absolutely
none of that don't get me wrong
after college I had my fair share of
adventures
[Music]
but I guess I just wanted to do more I
wanted to meet more people like really
actually meet more people I wanted to
hear their stories and I wanted to share
their stories with
I had this idea and the next day before
I could second-guess any of it I grabbed
my stuff and I made my first episode
[Music]
Wow that's a hard question and Here I am
one year later I've made 134 episodes
I've had five hundred and thirty six
thousand views and I've met 25 thousand
people 20 so as you could probably
imagine I've asked a lot of questions
this year but the one question everyone
keeps asking me is what have you learned
doing this so here it is real quick a
list of things I've learned from doing
this project what but I've learned that
rejections will always hurt but that's
okay because no man has heard compared
to how good this
[Music]
portrait wrong mr. Jarvis
[Music]
- yes it is possible to run out of good
questions but it's impossible to run out
of good answers three as cliche as it
sounds it's true that we really are more
similar
like my name is Sarah Sarah Dave David
Archer David Archer Chris Chris John
John John my name is Jonathan Eric my
name is Eric
we all dream and we all fail we all get
our hearts broken because my brother
passed away and that's what I would love
me
learning to accept it talk about it
it's been on the hunt and city 14 years
now it's you know will refused to give
up on love and people
[Music]
for that it's beautiful to be happy but
we're also beautiful when we cry and
it's okay to talk each other I thought I
just go out and some people on things
that I think are beautiful beautiful
beautiful beautiful okay
and five I've learned that words hold a
lot of weight and I understand why
people are scared to use them but I
admire people who found our words and
aren't scared to share it with the
stranger holding a camera
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]